hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing the history
of Voldemort's Faithful Servants the
Death Eaters specifically we'll be
looking at their founder how they formed
what name they originally operated under
how you can become a Death Eater why
some members weren't pure Bloods their
role in both Wizarding Wars and what
happened to the Death Eaters after the
second Wizarding War had ended let's get
into it Tom Riddle it all started with a
young orphan boy by the name of Tom
Riddle who began attending Hogwarts
School in 1938 though on the outside
riddle appeared to be a normal young man
deep down he had an unimaginable number
of demons demons that haunted him every
single day of his life why well Dom
didn't exactly have a normal childhood
he was abandoned by his witch mother
maripi gaunt the steps of War's
orphanage right the time of his birth
marapi was a pure blood witch and the
daughter of marvolo gaunt an evil wizard
and descendant of Salazar sutherin
marapi grew up in a small town called
little hangleton and in her later years
developed an obsession with a muggle
that lived nearby Tom Riddle senior a
handsome and wealthy muggle at one point
in time both nairapi's brother and
father were banished to Azkaban which
meant that she was in their little Shack
in Little hangleton by herself alone for
months on end with nothing but time to
let thoughts Fester this only fueled
marapi to take action on her obsession
with this local muggle man however she
didn't know how she was going to
approach it what could she offer this
handsome wealthy muggle she didn't have
much and though she was a wedge she
wasn't even particularly good at before
magic the result of suppressed magical
capabilities through years of abuse from
her brother and father but eventually
therapy did come up with an idea she
would create a love potion and with her
newly liberated circumstances life
without her brother and father her
magical abilities had blossomed just
enough for her to be able to produce one
eventually maripi got an opportunity to
give riddle the potion that she had
concocted likely in a glass of water or
some other drink and from this point
their relationship snowballed right
after drinking the potion he became
infatuated with therapy and just a few
months later the two were married and
therapy was pregnant with Tom's child
things were going great for the pair but
one day it weighed heavy on maripi's
heart that she may just be living a lie
was their whole relationship just a
product of the potion eventually maripi
dropped the Enchantment of middle senior
hoping that he would love her regardless
but of course this backfired massively
and riddle immediately left merapi
leaving her pregnant and destitute after
losing her husband maripi had lost her
will to live which prompted her in one
last Act of hopeless desperation to head
towards orphanage in London where she
would leave young Tom on the front steps
her dying wish was that the boy be named
after his father Origins because Tom
Riddle Jr never had a mother or father
figure he also never had any concept of
Love or family like many powerful evil
and enigma figures of History Biddle had
a rough start to his life and this paved
the way for the dark path that he was
destined to follow but when riddle
eventually began to act on his dark
nature and began pursuing dark Endeavors
he wasn't alone and he was able to bring
many other dark witches and wizards
along for the ride Q the first iteration
of the Death Eaters the Knights of all
purgis in an interview with Newsround in
2003 Rowling first reveals a snippet of
information about a group that preceded
the Death Eaters here is the history of
the Death Eaters and I don't know that
I'll ever actually need it but at some
point they were called something
different they were called the Knights
of all paragus I don't know if I'll need
it but I like knowing it I like to keep
that sort of stuff on hand who were the
Knights of wulpergus what's that all
about who were they
after being discovered in wool's
orphanage Tom was introduced to the
Wizarding World which meant that just
like most other young magical children
he ended up attending Hogwarts and as
you can probably imagine Tom ended up in
southern house Tom may have lacked
certain necessary human emotions but
that didn't mean he couldn't control
people his cunning and manipulative
nature eventually meant that he would
form a gang of Swords a group consisting
of his fellow Southern students he had
convinced these witches and wizards that
he was their friend and gained their
trust but in reality riddle had no
desire for friends and simply wanted to
use them for his own selfish endeavors
The Gang That riddle formed was once
described by Dumbledore who worked at
Hogwarts during this time as a mixture
of the weak seeking protection the
ambitious seeking glory and the thuggish
seeking a leader who could show the more
refined cruelty so the Knights of
warpacas were fellow Slytherin students
that were classmates of Tom Riddle sure
but where on Earth did that name come
from from what I've been able to find
the closest thing relating to all pergus
that makes sense is all purgisnat or
will purgis Knight which is a pagan
holiday that falls on the eve of the
feast of Saint wall Burgess a saint of
the Roman Catholic Church while purgis
Knight was when according to the belief
of millions of people the devil was
abroad when the graves were opened and
the dead came forth and walked when all
evil things of Earth and air and water
held Ravel all-purpose night has also
been associated with witchcraft in
German folklore for example will perkis
Knight gathers witches from all over the
land together for a great Sabbath on top
of the broken also known as the bloxburg
the highest peak of the hearts mountain
range but if we fast forward to the year
1970 32 years after Tom Riddle had
started attending Hogwarts and the
beginning of Voldemort's rise to power
these Knights of all pagus were known by
a different name Death Eaters as far as
dark witches and wizards went the Death
Eaters were the worst their group was
comprised of evil witches and wizards
that were all hell-bent on pursuing
their dark Ambitions they were the
followers of Lord Voldemort and they
obeyed his every bidding in an effort to
cleanse The Wizarding World the ultimate
goal being to restore pure blood
Authority they were pureblood Radical
supremacists ever bloodthirsty and
always more than eager to resort to the
darkest of Deeds if it meant achieving
their goal of blood Purity recruitment
some of Voldemort's Death Eaters had
been with him since the beginning fellow
classmates and members of his original
gang I suppose another portion of the
Death Eaters came from the family
lineage of the original members but how
did Voldemort recruit the rest of his
followers by the year 1970 Voldemort
controlled an army who gets to
officially decide who becomes a Death
Eater did they just let in anyone that's
in alignment with their cause is it
purely up to Voldemort to decide on new
Death Eaters or can existing Death
Eaters invite new witches Wizards to
join their group we know for sure that
there's some kind of recruitment process
in Play Because Dumbledore and Slughorn
discuss it in the Half-Blood Prince what
would the Death Eaters want with the
poor broken down old buffer like me
demanded slocorn I imagine that they
would want you to turn your considerable
talents to coercion torture and murder
said Dumbledore are you really telling
me that they haven't come recruiting yet
there are a few reasons why someone like
Slughorn would be a target for
recruitment first of all Horus corn is a
pure blood Wizard and I imagine that's
probably the most important aspect that
the Death Eaters consider when bringing
in someone new they are working against
witches and wizards with dirty blood so
bringing anyone on with dirty blood
themselves wouldn't make much sense
there are a few exceptions that have
slipped through the cracks like Snape
who is a Half-Blood however I imagine
these exceptions are only made for
witches and wizards that are extremely
powerful talented and have a significant
amount to offer to their cause that's
probably the second requirement for
recruitment some form of magical Talent
any kind of magical Talent can very
easily translate into Sinister magical
application and that's probably the
other main reason that they targeted
Slughorn these requirements established
I have a couple of theories for how
Death Eaters are formally recruited my
first theory is that Lord Voldemort hand
picks all subjects himself and simply
sends his followers off to retreat
retrieve them he's an incredibly
powerful wizard with the ability to read
people's minds and I think that with all
of his talents he would be the best
person to choose his own followers as he
would be able to quickly figure out if
they were truly in Allegiance with him
or not Voldemort makes an executive
decision on who he wants and if they
don't agree to his terms they either
Join or Die my second theory involves
Voldemort's existing followers and a
sort of Death Eater sponsorship program
which would allow Death Eaters to bring
on new recruits vouching for them you
would be brought before Lord Voldemort
at which point he would analyze you
likely using legitimacy to uncover your
true intentions he would then set you
off on some kind of initiation to prove
to him that you are worthy what this
initiation would involve is not stated
anywhere but I would imagine that
similar to joining a gang it would
involve a hit or Sinister Act of some
sort the Death Eaters are all huge
components of the unforgivable curses so
I would imagine that it would involve
them in some capacity perhaps having to
control torture or kill someone or maybe
even a combination of the three after
successfully completing your mission you
would then return to Lord Voldemort and
he would either approve or deny your
application if you weren't worthy I
expect he'd just kill you and if you did
prove your worth I suspected Voldemort
to one of the existing Death Eaters
would come along and engraved the
Sinister Mark of the Death Eaters on
your arm the dark mark just because
you've joined Voldemort's ranks it still
doesn't mean that you're an official
Death Eater in order to truly be
considered one of his serpents the Dark
Mark needs to be magically edged into
the skin the dark mark is a fair
inspiring symbol that represents their
goal of cleansing The Wizarding World
and is used by them as a way of inciting
fear in the general population often
projecting it into the sky using the
occurs
then he realized that it was a colossal
skull composed of what looked like
Emerald stars with a serpent protruding
from its mouth like a tongue as they
watched it Rose higher and higher
blazing in a haze of greenish smoke
etched against the black sky like a new
constellation Arthur Weasley had a lot
to say about the symbol you know who and
his followers sent the dark mark into
the air whenever they killed the terror
it inspired you have no idea you're too
young just picture coming home and
finding the dark mark hovering of your
house and knowing what you're about to
find inside everyone's worst fear the
very worst a distinction should be made
between the symbol that is projected
into the sky and the symbol on their arm
however as the one in the sky is a
simplified version of the one they bear
on their arm which is much more
intricate this Mark was reserved for
Voldemort's most loyal devout and most
important worthy followers which is why
someone like greyback a werewolf never
received this honor ranks allies with
the aforementioned distinction made
between Wizards with a dark mark and
someone like fenrir who merely served
the Death Eaters I thought I'd discussed
the Death Eater chain of command or
hierarchy it goes something like this
Voldemort is at the top his most senior
Death Eaters in a circle are below him
lower ranking Death Eaters still
brandished with the dark mark are below
them followers of the Death Eaters
without a dark mark but who were allowed
to wear deathy to garments were below
them and everyone else who followed
Voldemort was below them his innermost
Circle was comprised of people like
Bellatrix Barty Crouch Jr dalahov
Rookwood yaxley Snape and Malfoy to name
a few this circle also likely included
those who went to school with him and
were members of the Knights of ulpurgis
the lower level death were comprised of
family members of his inner circle Death
Eaters that had only recently joined the
cause and those who weren't respected
Enough by Voldemort to deserve being any
closer to him this group were given more
menial tasks in comparison to his
innermost Circle the next level down
were followers of Voldemort that were
not granted deathy to status or given
the dark mark but were allowed to wear
deathy to garments in order to command
the respect they engendered this group
was comprised of individuals at
Voldemort found useful but did not want
to directly associate himself with a
good example of someone in this category
would be Fenway greyback the next level
down was comprised of everyone else this
included individuals who served him
under the imperious curse individuals
who were pressed into Death Eater
service out of fear and of course their
many allies allied with the Death Eaters
were all manners of dark creatures
including Giants Dementors and
werewolves who were all convinced to
join Voldemort's cause by way of false
promises the latter group in this
hierarchy was used as cannon fodder
during Voldemort's initial Advance on
Hogwarts first visiting War by the year
1970 Voldemort and his group of Death
Eaters were organized and ready to wreak
havoc on the Wizarding World this year
marked the beginning of the first
Wizarding war and 11 years of conflict
that would follow this was the first
official reign of Lord Voldemort and as
the years went by he only grew more and
more powerful most Death Eater activity
during the first Wizarding War consisted
of stealth attacks torture Espionage and
mass killings and most often these
attacks were by order of Lord Voldemort
but not always sometimes the Death
Eaters orchestrated their own mass
killings and this fact inspired Terror
in The Wizarding Community the first
upiting war was a time of fear as The
Wizarding Community hadn't seen anyone
even remotely comparable to Voldemort
since Grindelwald but even then
Voldemort was new he was dangerous and
unpredictable there was a lot of
uncertainty and Voldemort's powerful
Legions of followers only helped
contribute to the ominous feeling of
what might happen to the Wizarding World
after Voldemort's initial fall at the
hands of Lily Evans and Harry Potter it
took a long time for the Death Eaters to
catch on to them Voldemort was this
powerful and Untouchable almost Godlike
figure if he had gone missing then
surely he couldn't have been defeated
some continued to commit atrocities in
Voldemort's name trying to figure out
information about his whereabouts such
was the case with Bellatrix rodolfus and
rabistan Lestrange and body crunch Jr
who tortured the long bottoms to
Insanity trying to get information from
them others namely the lower Downs fell
into chaos without Voldemort's direction
or Comfort brought from being tied to
his regime the remaining Death Eaters
were left with few options
and this is when the ministry of magic
along with the Order of the Phoenix
decided to take action with the
temporary legalization of the
unforgivable curses the good guys went
after the remaining scattered Death
Eaters and began to take them out one by
one many were killed many were
immediately imprisoned and a few of them
went to trial some were even able to
elude Justice by claiming that they had
merely been serving Voldemort due to the
imperious curse but one thing was for
sure this marked the end of the Death
Eaters at least for a little while
second was adding more thirteen years
after Voldemort's initial downfall and
the defeat of the Death Eaters the
ominous dark curse
was cast into the sky at the Quidditch
World Camp signaling the return of
Voldemort's followers for many this was
a tough pill to swallow as it likely
meant that Voldemort 2 had returned
though this was not confirmed for a few
more years this was the first Death
Eater attack in over a decade and it was
a sign of more horrible things to come
after getting his body back Voldemort
summons the remaining Death Eaters to
the little Angleton graveyard where he
makes an announcement welcome Death
Eaters 13 years 13 years since we last
met yet to answer my call as though it
was yesterday we are still United under
the dark mark then or are we I smell
guilt there is a stench of guilt upon
the air I see you all whole and healthy
with your powers intact such a prompt
appearances and the I asked myself why
did this band of wizards never come to
the aid of their Master to whom they
swore Eternal loyalty and I answer
myself they must have believed me broken
they thought I was gone they stepped
back among my enemies and they pleaded
innocence and ignorance and bewitchment
the motivation for Voldemort's monologue
was disloyalty as many of his followers
disappeared into the Shadows after his
disappearance making no effort to find
their Master however this was not the
case for all of his followers as people
like Bellatrix and Barty Crouch Jr
remained loyal to The Bitter End
searching for him for many years this
group of Death Eaters with the absence
of a few who didn't return his call then
found 13 years of repayment to Voldemort
a Penance for their wavered loyalty and
it was the same group of Death Eaters
that caused all sorts of Mayhem in the
lead up to and during the second
Wizarding War
between the battle of the Department of
mysteries the battle of the astronomy
Tower the battle of the seven Potters
the fall of the ministry of magic and
the Skirmish at Malfoy Manor the second
Wizarding War resulted in copious
casualties on both sides but it wasn't
until the Battle of Hogwarts and the
defeat of Lord Voldemort at the hands of
Harry that the Death Eaters met their
ultimate end this time Voldemort's
horcruxes had been destroyed taking away
any possibility of him returning and his
senior Death Eaters were dead which
eliminated any possibility for a future
Resurgence after the war after the
battle of Hogwarts there was only one
thing that mattered Lord Voldemort was
dead and with his end The Wizarding
World was finally free from the terror
that shook it to its core for the past
few decades but even though Voldemort
was gone and the Death Eaters had
dissolved not all of the dark Wizards
who took part in the Battle of Hogwarts
were dead what happened to them
conventional wisdom would point to
Azkaban just like the Death Eaters from
the first Wizarding War the dark Wizards
from this conflict were being sent back
to that Wizarding prison to serve life
sentences only this time they had no
chance of ever getting out but there's
always the possibility that some walked
free narrowly escaping the justice
system and dropping off the map entirely
we may never know what happened to
individuals like electo and Amicus Caro
who tortured the Hogwarts students
during Snape's tenure as Headmaster or
Augustus Rookwood an unspeakable for the
ministry of magic if you want a full
Deep dive into what happened to the
Death Eaters after the war I've covered
this topic as well and that concludes
today's video I hope you learned a
little bit about the history of the
Death Eaters if you have any remaining
questions on the topic or have any topic
requests be sure to comment them down
below and until next time remember it
does not do to dwell on dreams and for
forget to live
[Music]